votre soirée spéciale élections
départementales continue sur france 3 en
bourgogne avec des résultats toujours
nous allons nous intéresser au
département de la côte d'or avec un
rappel de certains de ses résultats
définitifs elle a besoin
alors c'était un canton convoité par le
front national est bien il arrive en
tête à brazey en plaine 39% des
suffrages il y aurait une transition du
lierre la semaine prochaine front
national ump ps au 2e tour à montbard on
se dirige vers un duel droite gauche au
deuxième tour marc frot laurence porte
sont en tête
ils sont devant patrick molinoz et
marion en main gauche on a dit joe
premier on c'est un canton urbain la
droite et devant la droite devant le
tandem ps europe ecologie les verts à
dijon 2 duel gauche droite au deuxième
tour le maire de dijon alain millot et
sa première adjointe nathalie koenders
sont en tête
ils seront opposés à l'ump à dijon 3 la
gauche arrive en tête également elle
sera opposée à la droite et au front
national la semaine prochaine dijon 4
lots ps en ballottage favorable et
socialistes sont devant à vue mp et le
front national
le canton de dijon saint avec la gauche
est en tête également la collecte pau
par christophe avena devance le binôme
udi divers droite franck eya à média
novo dijon 6 duels gauche front national
au deuxième tour andré gervais céline
maglica qui étaient avec nous tout à
l'heure sont devant le front national
edouard cavens avec nous sur ce plateau
et sa colistière arnay le duc il y aura
une triangulaire la semaine prochaine
dans cet immense quand on les
socialistes sont en tête ils sont suivis
du front national et de la droite à
nuits-saint-georges trois nuits saint
georges pardonnez-moi trois binômes sont
qualifiés pour le deuxième tour
les duos de droite le tandem du front
national et le
conseiller sortant voilà à talons une
triangulaire le ps est en tête ils se
maintiennent également le tandem divers
droite ump est le front national et puis
enfin semur-en-auxois la gauche est
éliminé il y aura un affrontement droite
front national la semaine prochaine il
en jeu prochain merci les ados dans la
parole à tous les partis présents pour
ce premier tour des départementales
prenons la direction de dijon avec
philippe hervieu pour europe ecologie
les verts bonsoir philippe hervieu on
s'aperçoit que là où le ps s'était uni
il est relativement au funk l'union de
la gauche fonctionne ça n'a pas été le
cas partout quelle est votre analyse
vous ce soir à écouter l'union de la
gauche fonctionne on le vole à dijon
puisque notamment sur le canton de dijon
3 ou 10 juin aussi où le binôme europe
ecologie les verts ps fonctionne plutôt
bien voire très bien fonctionné donc
mais par contre je trouve que les
résultats sont aussi bons quand les
europe ecologie les verts se présente
tout seul sous ses propres couleurs
à chalon à mâcon voir à nevers donc où
on fait des scores entre 8 et 11%
il y as forcément un appel à battre la
droite et l'extrême droite
alors on va regarder ça quand on part
content bien sûr dès demain matin mais
on va analyser les situations mais
évidemment on va appeler à battre la
droite et surtout à battre l'extrême
droite qui dans notre région est forte
en y compris dans l'yonne y compris dans
l'yonne où vous seriez une stratégie
d'alliance avec le front de gauche
contre 6 il est donc dans l'yonne on
avait une stratégie plutôt front de
gauche d'union avec le front de gauche
qui a fonctionné aussi donc il faut
qu'on regarde tout ça en détail ce qui
ne sont pas encore nous répondre
philippe hervieu
excusez moi je n'entends pas oui je vous
disais ce qui est une façon de pas
encore nous répondre sur des soutiens
systématique par exemple ou pas n'ont
écouté nous pour l'instant il faut
encore une fois je vous répète ce que
j'ai dit on va regarder les situations
quand
par canton et on va appeler on va
appeler évidemment à faire barrage
surtout à l'extrême droite
et puis examiner les situations canton
par canton et essayer de faire aussi
rage à la droite quand ce sera possible
parce qu'il sera donc demain merci
philippe hervieu c'est bien noté nous
inviter nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
en direct colette popard bonsoir bonsoir
le parti socialiste et candidate sur le
canton de dijon 5 et françois xavier
dugourd bonsoir bonsoir la candide et à
vous aussi sur le canton de dijon 1 et
puis pour le front national edouard cave
un bon soir secrétaire départemental du
parti et candidat sur le canton de dijon
six binômes l'est oui un petit bout si
on voulait résumer la situation en côte
d'or globalement la majorité ne changera
pas mais c'était plutôt attendu on va
dire que la gauche en l'état actuel des
choses il me regarde méchamment colette
pop ya peu de chances que la majorité
bascule en tout cas entre la droite et
la gauche
tanks et autant que les élections sont
passées elles ne sont jamais j'ai certes
bon alors prenons des gants disons que
globalement la gauche résiste sur son
point fort de l'agglomération dijonnaise
et que le front national va être présent
dans un certain nombre de cantons en
particulier dans les zones rurales voilà
c'est un résumé pour lancer objectifs et
la discussion une tentative avec une
belle résistance donc du parti
socialiste à dijon on voit même françois
xavier dugourd vous allaitez me vous
même en ballotage c'était une mauvaise
surprise ça pour vous les crues j'avais
cru pouvoir être élu au premier tour
du fait de l'abstention aux dernières
élections où j'avais fait 47 %
cette fois ci je fais 45% mais sauf que
la dernière fois ya pas d eau qu au
niveau national donc c'est les données
dont je considère que j'ai fait un bon
premier tour en étant et je crois que
tous les observateurs le reconnaissent
comme d'ailleurs la majorité
départementale a fait un bon premier
tour
maintenant il reste une semaine de
l'élection c'est en deux tours et donc
on verra dimanche prochain mais nous
sommes bien placés sur un certain nombre
de cantons
je crois qu'effectivement nous allons
pouvoir sylvie ritter le confirme
confirmé à la majorité départementale à
la tête du département de la côte d'or
connais pas vous n'êtes pas sûr que la
gauche va ne va pas remporté cette
élection
non je passe sur la gauche ne comporte
pas cette élection moi ce qui me plaît
beaucoup dans les débats c'est que les
candidats qui ne gagnent pas sont
toujours très contente du score qu'ils
font
et notamment monsieur dugourd ici
présente très bien monsieur durement que
vous n'ayez jamais fait depuis que vous
êtes candidat c'est le plus mauvais
score que vous n'ayez jamais fait et je
voudrais expliquer aux électeurs du
rasoir différents toi parce qu'à force
de faire du pied des clins d'oeil au
front national
vous êtes dépassés sur votre droite vous
êtes dépassés sur votre droite parce que
vous n'avez pas arrêté de faire alors
une campagne en parlant de la fraude
sociale
en en parlant de sécurité résultat des
courses vous êtes aujourd'hui talonné
par le front national
talonné par le front national vous avez
sur dijon 3 une triangulaire avec le
front national
vous même vous êtes en difficulté vous
avez certainement gagné mais un front
national on essaie va devoir voter pour
vous attendez et et et à force de faire
des clins d'oeil au front national
eh bien vous vous trouvez aujourd'hui
mais monsieur sauvadet se retrouve
contre le front national aujourd'hui et
à dijon nous résistons et nous résistons
bien et ça c'est grâce à la politique
qui est menée par françois rebsamen en
premier temps et on est à la mi ou s il
meurt à la suite les gens faut pas
prendre les électeurs pour des imbéciles
a ils comprennent bien les élus de
terrain ils savent ce que c'est quand
ils sont sur place
qui s'occupe d'eux et caetera et votent
pour eux et c'est ce qui se passe à
dijon aujourd'hui mais croyez moi
d'ailleurs on le voit dans toute la
france mais entend le département à
force de faire du pied au front national
vous êtes en train de vous faire
dépasser par le fondation vient juste de
voir que ce qu'on nous fait du buzz est
assis là à côté de noms mais je crois
que la conception de la pop art est
assez simpliste en termes facilement
pour ces élections
d'accord on m'écoute et non la réalité
c'est que j'organise le front national a
réussi un exploit c'est d'être présent
dans tous les cantons de côte-d'or et de
france quasiment à quelques excès les
exceptions près et le résultat
aujourd'hui historique le front national
à des résultats qui lui permettent
aujourd'hui un ancrage local on va faire
à peu près sept ou huit second tour
notant les résultats définitifs ce qui
était du jamais vu évidemment la
question c'est combien d'élus parce que
les élus et ça permet pas que peut être
d'accord ou pas si ça lui fait plaisir
c'est qu'on l'élection n'est pas
terminée l'élection n'est pas terminée
je peux pas vous dire combien d'élus en
tout 15 ans dès 16h et raisons d'espérer
combien voilà mais un élu serait travers
on en a un seul en france aujourd'hui
dans toute la france on a un seul
conseiller général si on peut avoir un
débat conseiller départemental entendeur
vous avez gagné
quand enfin je pense qu'au niveau
national il y en aura peut-être de
gagner
pardon si vous remportez attente on vous
aurez 2 et du tout les jours vous avez
deux élus peut-être peut-être comment on
peut te porter au sein du conseil
départemental on parle du troisième tour
après il y aura l'élection d'un
président une charte qui est en train
d'être édité qui sera proposé à tous les
candidats
pas forcément ceux de l'ump d'ailleurs
se prête aussi bien du ps etc à tous les
candidats
et s'il accepte de rigoler de proposer
un pass comprends pas comment on peut
voter pour des candidats du front
national on les voit nulle part est ce
que vous avez fait une seule réunion
on vous a vu que ce sera dans toutes les
réunions de mon compte j'ai rencontré
les gens et si je fais 30% ce soir on
n'a pas eu 29 ennemis vous avez sur les
images à brazey-en-plaine s'était pas
votre quant au plus tard non je suis
passé en fin de journée au dépouillement
comme il était à 18 heures et à 10 juin
19h j'y suis passé parce que c'est un
canton oui vous vous espérer qu'un score
voilà on l'a fait plus de 40% sur un
canton pour un parti c'est quand même
assez impressionné la suite de 2011
c'est que oui c'est sûr du domino le
canton n'était plus le même beaucoup
plus grand et le résultat que vous savez
par rapport à ce résultat dans les
campagnes moi je crois que c'est aussi
la faute de la droite parce que quand la
droite n'arrête pas de dire que le rural
et des lycées que les politiques ne
s'intéressent pas aux ruraux que et
cetera et cetera les ruraux le croit et
résultat des courses le front national
monte et c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure en préambule de mon propos à
front national
parce que vous êtes à ce que les choses
se passent comme ça le l'ump est en
train de déborder moi je vois sur mon
canton 1
l'ump est au coude à coude avec le front
national écoutez moi je suis sur le
plateau depuis cinq minutes
madame pulvar a prononcé au moins dix
fois les mots front national c'est quand
même extraordinaire
on est dans une exception départementale
conseil général des compétences 575
millions d'euros de l'action sociale
petite enfance personnes âgées personnes
handicapées les collèges des routes elle
n'a pas dit un mot sur ce sujet le seul
mot à la bouche chez front national
c'est le seul argument qu'a ps
aujourd'hui pour essayer de se sortir de
la situation désespérée dans laquelle il
est au niveau national et j'ai aucune
leçon à recevoir de vous je déjoue le
mainate se sentent jeu d aucune
ressource sans recevoir de l'audience
nationale madame papa je vous
rappellerai simplement que le président
du conseil régional il ya quelques
années du ps étaient issus de
gouvernement ps a été élu avec les voix
du front national
donc vous n'avez pas vous n'avez pas de
leçons à nous donner et au sol on peut
en attester nous continuons la
discussion qui sont en donnant la parole
à d'autres départements
vos valeurs je ne partage pas bouclé
national très clairement nous continuons
les discussions sur l'accord
partons pour la saône et loire avec
quelques résultats elle a besoin avant
de retrouver le président sortant rémy
chaintron el zhar par le contenu avant
l'élection au premier tour pour pierre
berthier josiane corneloup le tandem ump
divers droite élections également au
premier tour pour le tandem et de gauche
cette fois à cluny tandem jean luc
fonteray les et bête le mot non ps et
divers gauche à saint vallier en
saône-et-loire et y aura un deuxième
tour ps contre pc à chalon sur saône
duels fn ps c'est à chalon 1 il y à 13
voix d'écart entre le front national et
le tandem ps divers gauche à châlons 3
cette fois-ci duel gauche droite
dimanche prochain
le mpd devant le parti socialiste à
digoin sont qualifiés pour le deuxième
tour la liste divers droite et la liste
ps à paray le monial il y aura un
deuxième temps ump ps et puis enfin à
cuiseaux le camp dit
socialiste sortant frédéric cannard est
en tête son tandem avec sylvie quand il
ya sera opposé à la liste divers droite
et eiffel et puis enfin va terminer par
le canton de louhans c'est le canton du
président socialiste sortant rémy
chaintron qui est en difficulté puisque
sa liste ps est derrière est en
ballottage défavorable derrière la liste
ump divers droite
merci les araignées chanteront nous
attend justement en saône et loire avant
de le retrouver présentation des enjeux
donc dans le canton de louhans ce qui
s'est passé tout à l'heure il y avait
trois binômes en compétition reportage
de michel gillot et jean louis saint tin
ce n'est pas une vague bleu marine mais
une vague bleue tout court qui a
submergé le canton de louhans rémi
chaintron président du conseil général
sortant et candidat ps s'est largement
fait distancer par les jeunes candidats
de l'ump au moment du dépouillement
très vite le duo anthony baldo et
mathilde challut me vire en tête au fur
et à mesure que s'ouvrent les enveloppes
un constat s'impose l'ump est le grand
vainqueur de ce premier tour ont frôlé
la barre des 50% ont la cote à 40 89 %
bon c'est un très bon score après si on
doit faire à un second tour est bien bon
on va tout donner dans la semaine qui
vient pour je pense qu'on va continuer à
avoir la même démarche de proximité et
continuer
ce message qu'on veut passer de dire de
rendre à ce mandat son côté de proximité
on a fait ça pendant toute la campagne
du premier tour et on va continuer plus
de 48% pour la droite à peine 30% pour
la gauche c'est la douche froide
le parti socialiste pourrait voir la
présidente du conseil général lui
échapper même dans la commune de montrer
où madame le maire était candidate
c'est encore l'ump qui arrive premier
avec cinq voix d'avancé dans la presse
sur les terres de neuburg la gauche n'a
pas réussi à rassembler les faits
montebourg n'a peut-être pas forcément
eu lieu voilà il est
il n'a pas je pense pas lieu ce n'est
plus le même là même on dirait même
engagement je pense la population
vous pensez que vous payez aussi bas la
politique du gouvernement et la santé
sans doute la politique nationale mais
il faudrait que nos électeurs
comprennent qu'ils gagnent politique
locale qu'il s'agit de défendre avant
tout
le duel du second tour se jouera entre
l'ump et le ps le fl qui malgré sa
percée dans les petites communes n'a
obtenu que 20 % des voix pas assez pour
se maintenir dimanche prochain voilà
pour la situation à louhans rémi
chaintron nous attend en direct bonsoir
rémi chaintron président sortant du
conseil général de saône-et-loire
relative mauvaise surprise pour vous
dans votre canton de louhans ce score
bah écoute et oui on s'attendait
effectivement à pouvoir faire un
meilleur score je crois que
effectivement on paye aussi certaine
défiance vis-à-vis du parti socialiste
je n'ai jamais caché mon étiquette
j'étais au mas carte et je la garderais
j'ai toujours dit que j'étais plus
socialiste que beaucoup d'autres et donc
c'est vrai que ça va être c'est un 2e
tour compliqué mais vous savez en
politique on a l'habitude des 2e tour
compliqué et donc on va tout faire pour
rattraper le retard
même si c'est vrai qu'il est important
ici ici même sur ce plateau lors du
dernier débat qu'on a consacré à ces
élections départementales vous défendiez
votre bilan dix ans que vous aviez à
saigner les les finances de ce
département vous avez de nombreux
projets je pense notamment au center
parcs etc
comment vous expliquez finalement que
voudront retrouviez dans une telle
difficulté sur un canton qui
rappelons-le en compte celui aussi
d'arnaud montebourg
c'est aussi une figure emblématique de
ce département 50 ans qui est
effectivement regroupe maintenant trois
cantons différents 1 puisqu'il ya une
partie de l'ancien canton de beaurepaire
les les quatre les quatre 7e de l'ancien
canton de beaurepaire en bresse le
canton de louhans où j'ai été élu depuis
2001 et réélu en 2008 au premier tour et
puis le canton effectivement l'ex canton
de montret d'arnaud montebourg - de
communes qui sont partis sur un autre
canton donc c'est vrai que c'était un
redécoupage un peu un peu compliqué
peut-être que nos concitoyens également
n'ont pas tout à fait compris suivi ce
qui s'était passé sur sur ce secteur là
mais pour atteindre les 20 mille
habitants c'était nécessaire maintenant
c'est vrai que je pense que nous avons
un extrêmement un bon bilan sur le
département moi ce qui me sert au delà
de mon cas personnel moi ce qui
m'importe c'est que la majorité reste à
gauche au sein du conseil général et
conseil départemental demain de de
saône-et-loire et donc au regard des
résultats de ce premier tour la majorité
tient plutôt bien avec tout d'abord déjà
un élu au premier tour qui ai-je envie
de montrer que je que je félicite et
puis on a pas mal de triangulaires il ya
huit triangulaire dont 6 sur lesquels le
ps est en tête des duels également sur
lesquels nous sommes également en tête
donc quand on fait l'ensemble des
additions et des comptes en récupérant
aussi des voix des partenaires de la
gauche de la gauche plurielle et bien
nous sommes en passe de pouvoir gagner
et garder cette majorité
vous n'êtes absolument certain c'est ce
qu'il y a quand même louhans donc votre
canton vous êtes quand même en
difficulté 10 gouttes un jeune âge - ça
va être très difficile de garder ce dès
maintenant
il y à tous les autres je parle pas
forcément de mon canton vous regardez
sur autun vous regardez sur regarder sur
chalon vous regardez sur la bresse sur
sur cuisery vous regardez sur un cuisant
cuisery temps dont vous regardez sur
gergy vous regardez sur chalon sud
voilà donc on a des possibilités
effectivement dans ce deuxième tour de
maintenir cette majorité à gauche
merci rémi chaintron direct de mâcon sur
france 3 bourgogne à l'art en continu
justement sur la saône et loire
avec les réactions cette fois à droite
pour l'ump celle d'andré à carey nous
l'écoutons globalement l'union de la
droite et de la société civile à plus
fort plus tôt fait de très très bon
score globalement dans l'ensemble des
cantons
le signe le plus positive on va dire ses
vis-à-vis du président sortant puisque
on est en pôle position
donc je pense que le 29 mars l'union
pour l'avenir de ces noirs peut gagner
c'est départementale et les gens le
choix cette fois ci uniquement entre
deux seules alternatives soit d'un côté
le parti socialiste qui continuera sa
gestion que l'on a fort critiquée ou
alors effectivement une équipe nouvelle
une équipe rajeunie et avec des
compétences diversifiées
c'est à dire l'équipe de l'union pour
l'avenir à saône et loire un petit bout
quand même eu lieu au moins sept
triangulaires dans le département oui
alors j'ai pas pris connaissance de
l'ensemble des résultats effectivement
on a des triangulaires mais je pense
qu'il va falloir revenir auprès des
électeurs bien leur expliquer dans les
situations qu'il n'y a que deux
alternatives possibles 2 soit
effectivement garder ce que l'on a c'est
à dire le parti socialiste qui adhèrent
à tout ce que le gouvernement fait ou
alors effectivement une équipe nouvelle
union pour l'avenir sun loire donc
l'alternative entre ces trois listes
elle est simple il faut vraiment aller
voter et convaincre les électeurs
d'aller voter pour l'union pour l'avenir
assène loire analyse andré accary
candidat donc sur le canton de paray le
monial vous le voyez donc en ballottage
et qui a donc au deuxième tour et au
drakkar également leader de l'opposition
en saône-et-loire changeant de
département à présent la nièvre avec
vous elle a besoin et le rappel de
quelques résultats n'ayant m'a d'abord
s'intéresser aux cantons de nevers 3 la
gauche est éliminé dans son contour duel
ump fn dimanche prochain la gauche qui
ne sera pas au second tour également à
clamecy affrontement droite front
national au deuxième tour on aura droit
à une triangulaire et ce sera à corbeny
avec un affrontement droite gauche front
national dimanche prochain à
triangulaire également ps fn ump à la
charité sur loire même scénario dans le
canton de varennes vauzelles ou le seul
duo ps pc de la bourgogne est arrivé en
tête
le fn est en tête dans un autre canton
daniel c fourchambault il sera opposé au
saut
au tandem ps au 2e tour et puis enfin le
fn en ballottage favorable également
dans le canton de nevers de le front
national qui se reposait à la liste
divers gauche ps dimanche prochain et
puis on va terminer avec un canton
emblématique celui de château chinon il
y aura aussi un duel la semaine
prochaine ps front national c'est le
canton du président sortant socialiste
patrice joly qui arrive en tête au
premier tour nous allons soit pas très
joli juste après liancourt mes patries
dieu qui pourra servir avec patrice joly
canton de clamecy alors desserte des
cantons héraultais ont été redécoupée
mais c'était le canton bernard bach
dengue qui a été président du conseil
général de la nièvre et qui avait tenu
dans les pires tempêtes pour la gauche
jusque là c'est à dire les années 90 les
cantonales de ces années là quand la
droite la gauche mitterrandienne été
sanctionné alors là c'est une division
de la gauche terrible autour de la ville
de clamecy en grande partie qui se paye
pour la gauche sur cette élection
mais tout de même il est un symbole sur
ce canton de clamecy le suicide de la
gauche la gauche est divisée
patrice joly nous attend depuis de verre
bonsoir président sortant socialiste du
conseil général pas très joli donc dans
votre canton d'abord un duel ps front
national pour le deuxième tour oui passé
et rebelote c'est comme un milieu en
2011 sont de la même configuration avec
là aussi un appel faite aux électeurs de
ce canton mais de ceux de la nièvre en
général pour leur dire que à eux de voir
quels sont les représentants de nos
territoires ruraux qui sont les mieux à
même de défendre la nièvre de défendre
la ville moyenne de ce département
nevers en particulier et faire attention
à cette duperie qui est celle du front
national ou à travers les candidats
qu'on ne connaît pas d'ailleurs souvent
bien le vote se fait pour marine le pen
qui il faut le savoir est une grande
bourgeoise parisienne et dont on peut
penser qu'elle connaît moins bien
peut-être que des élus de proximité que
nous sommes les enjeux de nos
territoires ruraux
je voudrais profiter de ce moment
également pour dire que nous avons
compris dans ce département et la
majorité départementale que je préside
jusqu'à maintenant a compris
la désespérance de nos territoires
ruraux et de nos villes moyennes et que
nous interpellons depuis deux ans le
gouvernement les responsables politiques
pour répondre à cette désespérance
locales et pour nous donner les moyens
de notre développement je veux dire que
au sein de l'assemblée départementale
nous agissons de manière efficace je
pense pour répondre aux attentes de
notre population et construire l'avenir
de ce département
je note d'ailleurs que les candidats qui
se représentent la majorité
départementale sous la bannière de vivre
la nièvre ne s'en sortent plutôt bien
résisté au regard de ce qu'est le
contexte national et je voudrais
profiter de cet instant qui m'est donnée
pour faire un appel à l'ensemble des
électeurs des électeurs de gauche des
électeurs de progrès des électeurs
républicains pour se réunir et faire
barrage au front national je le redis
requis électoralement constitue une
véritable du prix nous ne les
connaissons pas nous ne connaissent pas
leur projet jolie une connaissons que
marine le pen
patrice joly pardonnez-moi lilian melet
à dijon quelle est votre vision voûte ce
deuxième tour vous êtes attaqués par le
front national sur un certain nombre de
zones rurales et sur nevers il ya aussi
la présence des candidats on va dire
dans la suite des élections municipales
de nevers est ce que on peut dire
aujourd'hui de votre point de vue le
conseil général de la nièvre restera à
gauche au deuxième tour
ou est ce qu'il ya un véritable danger
pour votre majorité savez une élection
n'est gagnée que à l'issue du scrutin
donc je me garderai bien de d'être
foriic néanmoins je le redis je crois
que les résultats permettent de
témoigner que les électeurs de les
candidats de la majorité actuelle
sortante constitue à la fois de membres
du parti socialiste mais de personnalité
de progrès qui se reconnaissent dans les
valeurs de gauche
il me semble que ces candidats ont
plutôt bien résisté sont plutôt en bonne
posture pour réussir ce deuxième tour et
donc permettre à cette majorité qui je
crois a bien travaillé et surtout assure
interpellé là où il le fallait
les responsables sur les enjeux de je
redis de nos territoires ruraux et de
nos villes moyennes et je pense en
particulier à nevers merci patrice joly
en direct de nevers pour poursuivre sur
la nièvre frais je vous propose
d'écouter les réactions de 2
thuriau suit donc on l'évoquait des
municipales de l'an dernier denis
thériault avait envoyé plusieurs
candidats leurs binômes se présentait
pour ces élections départementales sous
la même étiquette que celle qu'il avait
proposé aux électeurs à nevers l'an
dernier écoutez la réaction 2 denis
thuriau globalement sur neuf cantons
nous allons nous maintenir dans quatre
cantons pour une première un nouveau
mouvement pour les départementales
nièvre à venir c'est plutôt satisfaisant
un canton est décevant sud vers 2 sur
les résultats sinon globalement nous
faisons effectivement notre rôle aussi
de tampon vis-à-vis du front national et
donc nous avons plutôt des résultats
pour une première fois qu'ils sont
largement positifs alors vous avez
effectivement évoqué le canton de nevers
de là où le front national arrive en
tête avec 76 voix d'avancé contre la
candidate sortante socialiste a critiqué
gatille de la part de miramion une
consigne de vote
dites nous tout est une consigne de vote
moi j'estime que je ne suis pas
propriétaire des votes et donc de
l'électorat j'estime qu'il texte ces
grands pour savoir ce qu'il a à faire
nous avons une charte nièvre à venir qui
est une charte promouvant les valeurs de
la république et de la démocratie
ce ne sont pas celles du front national
donc je pense que je suis suffisamment
clair en disant cela je pense que
l'ensemble des membres de nièvre à venir
et bien décideront de soutenir le
candidat qui a les valeurs républicaine
les mieux placés et qui nous ressemble
le plus mais vous même vous appelé à
faire barrage au front national vous
vous l'avait dit en début d'interview
moi je suis un mouvement aussi qui se
voulait donc qui se veut de proposer
autre chose donc autre chose que le
front national qui n'est absolument pas
une solution
maintenant il faut que les partis s'ils
veulent subsister se pose les bonnes
questions
parce que quand je vois le score du
front national sur le territoire mais a
fortiori dans la nièvre
il ya vraiment une responsabilité de
ceux qui nous ont dirigés de ceux qui
nous ont gouvernés
nous avons lancé lancé cette voie elle
est prometteuse et en tout cas elle
accueille des gens qui se serait sans
doute perdu contre front national
j'entendais monsieur gaillard se
prévaloir d'être élu à nevers s'il ne
verra venir n'avait pas existé en
auvergne aurait peut-être trois élus
front national au conseil municipal
nous avons fait passer le fonds national
de 11 et 8 points je le rappelle donc il
y en a qu'un c'est largement suffisant
donc bien sûr nous sommes aussi là
contre le front national a donné thuriau
voilà pour la nièvre un autre
département celui de lyon pour terminer
notre tour d'horizon avec des résultats
elle a besoin
oui à brienon sur armançon le front
national est en tête à l'extrême droite
sera opposé à l'ump au 2e tour la liste
front national en tête également à
pont-sur-yonne julien haut doubs le
conseiller de marine le pen et sa
colistière alexandrine ferrand épouse
d'edouard ferrand le patron du fn en
bourgogne affronteront les listes divers
droite et ps dimanche crochat dans le
canton de migennes la gauche est éliminé
au deuxième tour on retrouvera les
listes ump et front national
la droite est éliminée à joigny c'est le
fn qui est en tête là aussi le binôme
dior et garnier devance le ps à auxerre
pas de gauche au deuxième tour dans le
canton d'auxerre 2 le tandem ou des
divers droite et devant le duo front
national le canton de saint florentin
maintenant le fn est en tête aussi se
maintiennent également 2e tour le duo
divers droite
enfin joux la ville où c'est le canton
du président sortant lui dit andré
villiers ses colistières divers droite
ils sont en tête ils seront face au
front national au deuxième tour
merci beaucoup elsa andré villiers
candidat donc sur le canton de
joux-la-ville nous attend candidat et
président sortant pour le département de
l'yonne
bonsoir andré villiers d'abord peut-être
sur votre canton avant d'élargir sur
l'yonne en général bonsoir
bien écoutez c'est un exercice nouveau
que d'affronter d'aborder en tout cas
cette élection départementale dans un
dans une configuration territoriale qui
est celle de 21 cantons dans un
découpage qui a laissé là par les moins
belles à la proximité on voit que
effectivement les choses deviennent de
se banalise un petit peu deviennent plus
compliquées et le front national marque
sur ce terrain là effectivement un
certain nombre de points
bon je dirais que nous sommes habitués à
la présence du front national depuis
depuis très longtemps lorsque j'ai
commencé mes premiers pas en politique
départementale bien le front national
était déjà présent aujourd'hui sur mon
territoire sur notre territoire
avec colette lerman donc le front
national est crédité d'un score d'un peu
plus de 29%
nous sommes un peu plus de 41% bon nous
allons rencontrer cette semaine et bien
toutes celles et tous ceux qui
finalement ont à dire et est à craindre
au fond de la politique qui est conduite
au niveau gouvernemental et qui souffre
au quotidien
je veux parler des familles des artisans
des commerçants et nous aller nous
allons aller à leur rencontre et des
agriculteurs bien évidemment pour leur
expliquer que l'élection départementale
ne doit pas être prise en otage dans un
débat national qui veut adresser un
carton rouge au gouvernement donc ça va
être tout le propos de la semaine qui
s'annonce
vous considérez andré villiers que c'est
aussi un échec de la droite cette
progression du front national dans
l'yonne on sait que c'est un département
plutôt classé à droite historiquement
comment vous vous regardez ses scores
très élevés du front national et qui ne
cesse de progresser dans ce département
vous savez dire que c'est un échec de la
droite
sûrement pas parce qu'en fait nous
résistons dans un grand nombre de
situations
le deuxième tour s'annonce avec 12
elle entre la droite le centre droit et
le front national
trois duels entre la gauche et le front
national quatre triangulaires
nous avons un élu au premier tour il y à
un duel entre la droite et la gauche
donc finalement sur l'ensemble de la
carte du département et bien la droite
et le centre droit dans 50% des
situations que je viens d'énoncer est en
tête des résultats du premier tour
donc finalement la droite résiste quand
elle est unie et je veux souligner
d'ailleurs que dans la moitié des
territoires en question est bien le
centre droit incarné par l'udps et y
offre en tout cas une belle possibilité
de résistance puisque nous sommes unis
l'ump est en nous offrons en tout cas la
possibilité de de la victoire la
perspective de la victoire à l'issue du
deuxième tour donc dire que le front
national progresse certes mais ils
progressent en cristallisant l'ensemble
des des mécontentements d'où qu'ils
viennent et c'est un peu c'est un peu
l'auberge espagnole dans laquelle chacun
apporte dans sa besace et bien son lot
de récriminations et elles sont
nombreuses et je pense que en tout cas
le message doit être entendu de la part
du gouvernement
je dis bien que c'est un message adressé
au gouvernement plus qu'au département
puisque nous nous évertuons en tout cas
dans l'yonne depuis quatre ans à
restaurer la situation budgétaire et
financière nous y parvenons et ce n'est
pas en apportant les propositions de la
nature de celles qui sont apportées par
le front national qui finalement sont
très éloignés de la politique locale et
de la gestion départementale que on
améliorera la situation de nos
départements
mais finalement nous souffrons oui merci
beaucoup andré villiers pour cette
réaction n'a bien compris la situation
dans l'yonne cette montée vous disiez du
front national et justement nous allons
évoquer le canton de pont sur yonne où
le fn arrive en tête avec le binôme et
notamment julien d'où le voyez donc près
de 39% des suffrages pour le fn en
ballottage pour le deuxième tour écoutez
la règle
lyon 2 julien odoul on a fait un gros
travail sur ce canton cependant cette
campagne j'aimerais dire que ce soir
c'est un vote d'espoir vote d'espoir des
électeurs du canton qui par leur vote
ont voulu protéger le département voulu
protéger les politiques sociales ont
voulu donner un signal fort envoyé un
signal fort à la gauche de manuel valls
au gouvernement et puis à la caste ump s
voilà donc il ya une alternative
patriote est possible je leur demande à
tous très important de se mobiliser pour
dimanche prochain
tous les électeurs et les
abstentionnistes parce que l'alternative
patriote est possible sur ce canton
l'espoir que dès que toutes les
électeurs devient de la guyard jusqu'à
courtois ont exprimé par ce vote il peut
se réaliser dimanche prochain mobilisez
vous justement est-ce que le scénario de
ce premier tour
vous conforte est ce que vous voyez élu
dimanche prochain et bientôt siéger au
conseil départemental
ce sera aux électeurs d'en décider donc
quand le peuple le veut le peuple ne
peut donc je leur dis à tous qu'ils
peuvent par leur vote changer
durablement les choses leur quotidien au
département nous sommes le seul à
vouloir défendre département nous sommes
les seuls à lutter contre la gabegie à
lutter contre l'insécurité à lutter
contre l'immigration massive un contrôle
donc je leur dis à tous portez vous sur
notre sur notre candidature
où voter tous le dimanche 29 mars pour
alexandrine ferrand joyau de julien au
double d'un candidat à pont-sur-yonne
arrivé en tête pour le front national
dans ce canton du nord de l'yonne
nous continuons avec l'yonne on termine
le tour d'horizon de l'yonne avec un
direct nicolas soret qu'il nous a
rejoints pour une réaction directe
d'auxerre il est en train de se mettre
en place
bonsoir à vous votre première action
donc sur ses résultats dans l'yonne
c'est une élection qui a été difficile
pour nous dans un département qui est
comme d'habitude est habituellement
conservateur néanmoins bon on a quelques
quelques belles surprises dans notre
canton même si encore une fois de façon
générale ça a été très dur pour nous
droite gauche dans l'yonne c'est une
situation très très particulière et un
front national très fort une gauche
toujours aussi faible vous n'arrivez pas
à vous ancré dans ce département
décidément sauf dans les zones urbaines
comme chez vous comme à auxerre ou
villeneuve sur yonne
voilà tout à fait mais c'est vrai que ça
va on n'avait même pas présenté de
candidats partout parce que
effectivement on a du mal à s'implanter
dans dans ce département
enfin moi je remarque quand même que là
où on est là où on travaille le dossier
là haut depuis plusieurs années on a on
travaille les dossiers on essaye de
répondre aux attentes de la population
et bien finalement les scores ne sont
pas si mauvaise et c'est mon cas à
joigny et j'en suis heureux où je me
retrouve face au au front national pour
ce second tour
donc ça va être une élection
difficile mais moi je crois vous savez à
cette politique qui travaille pour
améliorer la vie des gens jour après
jour mois après mois en portant des
dossiers en développant le territoire en
arrêtant et en évitant qu'il continue de
s'enfoncer comme l'yonne le fait depuis
plusieurs décennies
donc oui là ou là où les habitants nous
ont vus à l'oeuvre et bien cela
fonctionne mais effectivement dans des
terres où jamais on a pu s'implanter
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué nicolas
soret l'aspect jouanny n'est pas le cas
le plus fréquent dans l'yonne le cas à
ces fréquences et qui aura la droite
face au front national
quelle sera votre attitude dans ces
situations là eh bien mon attitude est
celle que j'ai toujours eu depuis
toujours et sans ambages je vous dis que
partout où cela est possible il faut
faire barrage au front national et pour
être beaucoup plus clair partout où
faire barrage au front national ça
nécessite de voter pour l'ump ou lui dit
eh bien il faut le faire il faut le
faire nous n'avons rien à attendre de
conseillers départementaux issus du
front national ce nomadisme électorale
qui fait que des candidats se présentent
à l'autre bout du département parce
qu'ils ont une étiquette front national
bleu marine sans même connaître les élus
sans même connaître la population sans
même connaître les dossiers
ce n'est pas moi ma vision de la
politique donc partout où des élus sont
bien ancrés bien implanté qu'ils
travaillent leur dossier eh bien il faut
les favoriser face au candidat du front
national
merci nicholas ray en direct dos est
revenue en côte d'or à présent avec le
canton de dijon de celui où se
présentait le maire de dijon alain
milieu avec nathalie koenders vous voyez
le résultat de ce premier tour donc
ballottage avec le binôme ump divers
droite
voyons l'ambiance dans ce canton de
dijon de tout à l'heure avec ce
reportage de christophe taris et amélie
doué pour quelques voix seulement
il rate l'élection dès le premier tour
alain millot et nathalie koenders était
le symbole de la municipalité dijonnaise
ans et départementales et la gauche peut
être satisfaite elle est en tête dans
cinq des six cantons de la ville avec
une bonne participation
à dijon ii le plus peuplé ancré à gauche
depuis 2008 le duo entre le maire et sa
première adjointe se retrouvent donc
conforté avec +2 48% des suffrages
c'est pas un hasard si ça se passe à
dijon je pense que c'est dû au travail
de terrain des candidats de gauche des
différents cantons de bigeon qui sont
candidats certes aujourd'hui mais qui
sont aussi des élus et des personnes de
terrain d'écouté disponibilité
j'ajouterai également que conforter au
niveau de la ville de dijon mais aussi
d'après les résultats qui sont en train
de tomber
confortée au niveau de l'agglomération
dijonnaise de la communauté urbaine
pour le conseiller sortant de nolay
emmanuel bichot associés alors jahier
c'était un test pour sa capacité à
rassembler derrière son nom la droite
dijonnaise avec près de 32% des voix
il arrive en deuxième position mais avec
un écart de voix important ce canton
étaient présentés par la gauche comme un
perdable et ils annonçaient même une
victoire dès le premier tour
et bien ce soir je constate que le maire
de dijon et sa première adjointe et bien
sont en ballottage avec une grosse perte
par rapport à leur score des municipales
ils ont perdu 1000 voix sur 4500 sur ce
sur ce canton et nous nous retrouvons
effectivement comme le principal
opposant pour le deuxième tour en duel
avec nos adversaires socialistes car le
front national avec moins de 20% des
suffrages ne parvient pas lui à se
maintenir au second tour
deux résultats qui viennent de nous
parvenir concernant des cantons de
côte-d'or elsa curieux vient d avoir à
chenôve il y aura un duel front national
ps dimanche prochain et puis à
saint-apollinaire on se dirige cette
fois là vers un affrontement droite
front national au second tour
merci ezaley beaucoup été question de ce
front républicain pour faire barrage au
front national sur ce sujet je vous
propose d'écouter françois rebsamen le
ministre du travail il n'y a pas une
il n'y a pas une seconde d'hésitation à
avoir partout où on peut battre le
candidat du fn ce sera le rôle du
premier secrétaire de la négociation
bien sûr et bien nos candidats doivent
appeler à voter pour la droite
républicaine pour la droite républicaine
con
le fn mais le retour c'est normal c'est
que on en attend d'eux mêmes réactions
sur ce front républicain peut-être vous
edouard qu'à 20 fois plus je trouve ça
scandaleux depuis le début de l'été que
je suis arrivé sur le plateau on ne
parle que du fait qu'il faille battre le
front national systématiquement entendu
à toutes les sauces une fois contre
quand on est contre la droite quand on
est contre la gauche la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les français ont fait des
choix et il me semble que la première
des choses ça serait de les respecter
voilà c'est tout c'est tout ce que ça me
ça m'inspire comme réaction non
l'élection n'est pas fini mais on peut
au moins respecter le choix des français
quand ils portent des candidats qui font
plus de 40 % dans certains cantons nous
semble que c'est quand même la moindre
des choses c'est de respecter leur choix
et il faut les candidats du front
national ont été élus sur un programme
qui est défini qui écrire qui est précis
résonnait comme attraper entendu dans
les débats sur les élections
départementales même vous l'avais invité
j'en ai discuté ici
après vous pouvez inviter d'autres
candidats et vous aurez certainement dit
oui françois xavier dugourd on vient
d'entendre françois rebsamen dire qu'il
appellerait à voter pour le candidat de
la droite républicaine il attend juste
retour que sam a eu des positions
l'attaqué premièrement ras-le-bol de
cette politique où on se dit
propriétaire des voix des électeurs
pire les électeurs ils sont grands ils
vont décider en responsabilité par
rapport aux propositions qui seront
faites par les candidats
par ailleurs moi je rappelle que je ne
partage d'idées les valeurs du front
national ni celle du parti socialiste
je rappelle que le parti socialiste ne
souhaite pas lutter contre la fraude
sociale il a refusé le débat une au
conseil général
il souhaite augmenter le prix des
cantines scolaires mais je parle du
conseil général parce que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un débat sur les
élections départementales donc le parti
socialiste souhaite augmenter le prix
des tarifs
le tarif détaillé des cantines scolaires
c'est très clair puisque peu fixé c'est
dans le programme le prix des cantines
en fonction des revenus
le parti socialiste souhaite limiter la
libre la liberté anciennement ils
souhaitent arrêter stopper la politique
de soutien à l'enseignement privé comme
à l'enseignement public
donc voilà c'est sûr ça c'est sur ces
propositions que nous nous battrons et
par rapport au front national
on l'a observé effectivement des
professions de foi effectivement ya
relativement peu de propositions sur le
département
vous êtes voir sony si je comprends mais
très clairement il n'y a pas une tribune
qui comme moi aussi j'ai bien regardé la
profession de foi si vous voulez vous
retrouver dans les professions de foi du
front national la main la même chose que
dans les profils les professions de foi
de l'ump et donc je n'ai pas lu mais non
mais quand on sait qu'en la réalité sur
ses goûts de chaque fois que tu veux
lutter contre la fraude sociale ne vous
êtes même fait donner sinon c'est que
vous êtes fait donné une mission à coups
de contre la toux des 11 % 44 des
sangsues relationnel excusez moi du peu
donc vous ne savez pas quoi dire même
jour la sécurité moi je vais vous dire
je vais vous dire ce que je pense je
pense que vous avez une chose sur la
pêche raison c'est qu'il faut pas
prendre les électeurs pour des imbéciles
et moi je pense je les appelle à se
ressaisir et j'appelle ceux qui ne sont
pas alertés dès le premier tour à y
aller au deuxième tour parce que vous
avez entendu monsieur dugourd nini est à
dire qu'ils vont s'arranger comme ils
font d'habitude avec le front national
pour le troisième tour
c'est comme ça ça va pas demander pardon
donc il faut que les électeurs se
ressaisisent aux propos se ressaisissent
et a voté le 29 ans pour l'ensemble des
forces de progrès j'ai pratiqué dise les
choses
cette mission ne ferait barrage au front
national
quoi qu'en dise monsieur dugourd c'est
le jeu sur une primaire très clair nous
avons une politique ne s'est pas attardé
qui fait des mois que je n'allais pas ce
que vous lui fait du pied et qui
laissait une place aussi leur départ
seulement seul argument vous ayez depuis
45 mais c'est vrai pour mais c'est
vraiment très très mais c'est vrai la
preuve si vous avez vous avez fait que
44 cents le plus mauvais score comme le
jouet vogel et cher culte est le plus
mauvais histoire que vous n'ayez jamais
fait nous aurons l'occasion de revenir
vous avez évoqué ce deuxième tour durera
un deuxième tour dimanche prochain mais
d'ici là nous avons encore l'occasion de
débattre de ce premier tour avec
notamment demain à midi une édition
spéciale de votre 12 13 et également à
12h57 nous retrouverons pour à nouveau
un débat et l'essentiel des résultats
vous les retrouvez tous sur internet
france3 point fr d'ici là la soirée
continue avec carole gaessler et francis
letellier très bonne soirée sur france 3
rendez vous demain midi et à tout moment
sur internet
belle soirée